[Music]
imagine that your infinite consciousness
all right you're everything there isn't
anything that isn't you or could not be
you
right
one of your most prized creations would
be
a place where you could experience the
illusion of being separate from yourself
[Music]
so not too much
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation i'm your host alan sakhyan we
are still in los angeles california we
are now on the gorgeous venice boardwalk
we are going to be talking to david
alexander english about all things
related to life his art and the way he
communicates the inventory of his mind
out to civilization i'm super excited to
have this conversation thanks for
joining us on the show boom shakalaka
huge shout out to jason pinsky for
introducing us definitely much more
skate skate 20 dwarfs 20 dwarfs 20 dogs
okay so david who the hell are you
good question
[Music]
so uh
you want to hear the story of my name
yeah okay
so there was this woman named avis bean
who my mother knew is aunt avis she was
my mother's great uncle's girlfriend
during the depression and they all lived
in the same house when she was a little
kid
avis was in a coma in the hospital and
wasn't expected to live
and so my mother and grandmother went to
see her my grandmother's standing there
in the doorway talking to the nurse
and
my grandmother
and uh my mother walks up to the bed and
she puts her hand on avis's hand
and avis comes out of the coma
sits up in bed and she says hello mitzi
um
to my mother's nickname when she was a
little kid she said you're pregnant
you're gonna have a son and his name's
gonna be david alexander
she went back into the coma and a few
months later she died
[Music]
so growing up i heard this story a lot
and
so
in in a way it was kind of like in the
background of a walking meditation
um
to cut to the chase it's like
when it's hard to be anything other than
you know working towards being a
significant player on the planet
when
you know somebody has prophesied you're
coming
you know when you feel like
uh no matter where you are no matter
what's happening it's like okay so
i've gotta i've gotta make something
happen i've gotta do something with this
you know i can't just be a dishwasher i
can't just be a taxi cab driver but if i
am being a taxicab driver and a
dishwasher
um
there's something here for me to learn
something in this moment the universe
has brought me to this moment for a
reason you know so it's like you know
how do i harvest that
so who the heck is david alexander
english
that's uh i guess we'll know when it's
over right
seriously
in the meantime
it's all about you know
creating as much
work as i can creating as much of the
work that i've you know those moments
when you feel like this is why i was
born
this is why i came here right
um as much as many of those moments
as i can possibly create you know
and the more time you spend in that zone
of
you know
i i can't wait to create this thing i
can't wait to you know get to what am i
what do i get to do today oh okay i get
to paint this painting i get to write
this novel i get to make this movie
i get to fly this plane or just stand
here and just like dig on the fact that
there's a freaking plane in the air
isn't that amazing that i mean
i love seagulls i can just love seagulls
i can i can appreciate
the infinitude
of of my and everyone else's being
anytime i choose i can marvel
i can be in wonder
right
whatever's coming at me i have a choice
you know i i can choose to
you know
take it anywhere i want because we all
have spiritual sovereignty no matter
whether we want to abrogate that or not
you know whether we want to surrender
that to somebody else or not
so
who am i it's like
the blossoming
take a snapshot
right even this moment i mean this is
just
this is right now it's cool it's cool
it's yummy it's friggin yummy it's
maggie i'm late
but but then um
it's what's the context
do you need the context
you're going to learn something either
way
if you're you know those that have the
eyes to see in the ears to hear
right
so whoever's watching this
is there's an agreement
that was made
before we
chose to come into this world
that
there would be a moment
of possibility
of of inspiration of
of uh
self-initiation
right
and
honestly
i get
i feel
totally empowered and totally nourished
when
i i know that i've inspired people
you know to to remember who they really
are and and that we're all infinite and
immortal beings
right
so you got another question you want me
to keep going what
all right well there's a lot of good
stuff that you brought there i like the
you gotta do what it's like you gotta do
what you love every single moment of
life and and you got to think about what
the realization is is the educational
lesson that you're getting in every
single one of those moments
whether you are doing something
that may you may think is mundane or
ecstatic or sad or whatever it may be
it's all lessened
in this growth that we have
there are a lot of other things it's all
fertilizer yeah it's very footy
fertilizer
um
we have a choice
you know to pay attention or not
[Music]
one thing that we one thing that we do
say is that
one's
faculties need to be trained to see
things as everything is fertilizer the
children need to be trained to know that
not not really not trained okay you know
once again we're infinite and immortal
beings right
so we we all have chosen to be here
you know to to take part in this
unfolding
in this remembrance and this reawakening
right
and
nobody needs to be trained
unless they that they've chosen to be
trained we need to remember though
exactly but don't we need assistance
remembering from others some people do
and some people don't yeah
right i mean what are we remembering
exactly we're remembering our what if uh
infinitude
our immortal nature our tourist self how
are we immortal in our reason
and for for choosing to be born our
reason okay how what is our reason for
choosing to be born and how are we
immortal exactly
well oh you so so that's what you're
supposed to do for every person
right
okay so so i am born with an intention
to manifest some sort of uh destiny on
the planet of of of
hopefully creating some sort of
benevolent value to the system of earth
right
right and each one of us has a different
content that we landed here on earth
with right and we have to remember what
that intent was and some people don't
some people come with no intent no some
people don't need to
remember because they came here for what
they came here for whatever their reason
was but but to know to realize and
remember would be antithetical
anti-productive to the like like it's
like you know those times in your life
when you're like i really want to know
universally you don't there's like
crickets you don't hear anything you
don't get the information that you're
asking right one of the reasons why that
is
i've you know from my experience is that
to know the answer that question might
be
um counterproductive to you actually
doing
what it is that you came here to do
interesting yeah so
um you have to remain in the discovery
mindset
if that's what your mission is
right there are loads of people like 90
of the people on the planet
they're not in discovery they're not in
that's not their thing that's not what
they're here to do you know they're here
to to fully immerse
in the experience in the illusion of
being separate from the one
they're here to immerse themselves in
the separation and the illusion of being
i wouldn't say it's their lesson i i'd
say for some people it's their lesson
but for some people
if you know
it's for them to say what it what it's
for and what it is and okay but
[Music]
every person comes here
before they get here they they uh they
sit down with a
kind of a a group of super conscious
beingness right their own higher self
and there are there are certain aspects
of of the universe that present
themselves as super conscious beings who
their sole job is to remember what this
whole soul group every
every life path of every member of this
of this whole soul group all 7.8 billion
souls of us
is doing what what your mission is and
or what the mission is that you've
chosen for this incarnation
and to weave whatever that mission is
into
um the the highest good
right the the agenda of the highest good
so that no matter what it looks like on
the surface as a mortal person
to infinite consciousness it all makes
perfect sense not only does it make
perfect sense
it already knows what what all the
possibilities are it knows what you were
going to do before you you know
you entered the realms of density right
the realms of density are
you know the physical realm the the um
etheric realm the astral rum the causal
plane
right and and those places that are more
dense than the physical realm
um
we all come from beyond all that that's
a super conscious a place of super
consciousness total higher self place
right i try not to say higher self
because it's you know
higher is relative to what to what yeah
you know but when we come in
and it's misleading because it's it's
it's actually it's all within you
you know that hold it the keynote god is
within you it's all it's all within it's
you know so so
as
you said nine of ten you think are
here to experience the illusion of the
separation right to be totally
thoroughly immersed in that illusion
yeah and the reason is because the
source
of the one
that's its agenda
it's to experience the illusion of being
separate from itself that's the source
okay the source of the one the source of
infinite consciousness the source of
infinite love okay it's its
agenda because okay so let's take a step
back because that's the learning that's
how you learn okay hold on hold up
imagine that your infinite consciousness
[Music]
all right you're everything there isn't
anything that isn't you or could not be
you
right
one of your most prized creations would
be
um
a place where you could experience the
illusion of being separate from yourself
to the point where you would savor those
things that helped you remain in that
illusion for as long as possible because
let's face it
as long as possible is still just a blip
in your
infinity right
to the point where you would savor those
things like fear doubt anger confusion
you know
all that stuff
pride uh greed all those things because
they
energetically there those are energetic
structures that
it you know keep you
in the illusion
of being separate from you when you're
everything you're the sky you're the
earth you're the love you know you're
all the dimensions you're everything
right
you are
the creation and beyond the creation
there's anything in the creation or
beyond the creation that isn't you
all right
so what's the first thing that happens
when a person gets born
they forget everything
you forget who you are
and you spend a good slice of your life
trying to remember who the heck you
really are probably 30 years yeah easily
easily and most people never remember
who they really are
like 99.99999
of the population never remembers who
they really are because most people
they use the term soul
recognizing that a soul is immortal
intellectually but they don't recognize
we we don't usually recognize that that
we're immortal
right that this is our space suit
you know this is a spaceship how are we
immortal
you tell me
i don't know
yeah you do
all right yeah you do i mean if i was to
hypothesize maybe this
when this flesh vehicle spacesuit
ends the heart last heartbeat goes
that
maybe
i revisit another
spacesuit
maybe yeah
if that's what you you know that's if
that's your mission right but let's
before you leave the body i mean before
you leave the the planet for good all
right
every day
every person on this planet leaves their
body
every day every day dreams
dreams
but also in trance
in thought
you know it's faster than the speed of
light
look at that face
consciousness
right
so it takes
uh 26 000 years for light to get from
the center of the milky way galaxy to
your nose right
and
if i say
the sun of the milky way galaxy you're
there
in your mind
boom
instantly
okay
you know this is the metaphysics
the word metaphase a lot of people they
hear that word they're like huh what
what
it because it's a big word you know
there's more letters in it that most
people use in their regular vocabulary
and everything like that but
let's break it down
right meta
is greek for beyond
physical
as in the physical plane of existence
beyond the physical plane of existence
right
so what's beyond the physical plane of
existence
us
consciousness
right
our dreams our emotions you know our
aspirations our our thought forms you
know
one of the things you learn in in in
metaphysics in studying metaphysics is
that that thoughts are real things
thought is energy
you know energy is vibration everything
in the physical universe is vibration
you know the flower of life is the
is the a standing wave
the standing wave of energy that is the
physical universe
right everything in the physical
universe is
in the flower of life pattern
right the the flower of life is
uh
the electromagnetic field of the
universe
right of the physical universe this is
what some of your art is about yeah yeah
yeah so tell us about this the flower of
life the electromagnetic field of the
universe tell us about this so
so the
everybody knows the star of david right
the star of david is shorthand for the
flower of life
[Music]
all right to start tetrahedron
it's three-dimensional so it's a star
tetrahedron the star tetrahedron you
know it's up upward facing uh
tetrahedron and a downward facing
tetrahedron all right
um
so every line in the in the tetrahedron
is
um
essentially
take a step back
um
basic principle of physics is a moving
electrical field creates a magnetic
field and vice verse right so as an
electron moves from point a to point b
it warps the ambient field around it
into a magnetic field
right so if you picture a tetrahedron
with four you know there's four corners
and four
uh lines running between them all right
those four lines are the
electron moving around right and each
one of those lines has if you're going
to draw it in two dimensions it has two
curved lines on either side of it right
the two curved lines are the magnetic
field the straight line is the
electrical field
all right
the flower of life is made of
basically
two spheres
of
star tetrahedrons
interfacing with one another
[Music]
a lot
electromagnetically you know all these
electrons moving around but they all
have they all do the same thing which is
they create a magnetic field as they
move right
so
there's one of these around you
around every one of your cells
every one of your molecules every one of
your subatomic particles is one of these
around the earth around the solar system
and so forth no electromagnetic field
around every subatomic part and we call
it we call it the the flower of life
because the pattern
is everywhere there isn't anything that
can exist in the physical universe
unless it's that
it's the it's the way
the universe vibrates it's energy
and
it's conscious
it's infinite consciousness
so the physical plane is infinite
consciousness
everything is infinite consciousness
there isn't anything and the physical
plane is all in the flower of life all
in the yeah electromagnetic it all looks
in a flower it's a fractal it's a
fractal right within every one of those
spheres spheres is the whole pattern
repeats to infinity infinitely in and
infinitely out
i see your your mind is melting down my
friend
trying to chew on that like
yeah there's there's a lot to remember
yeah yeah exactly
you're getting
like
i don't know i'm 61. you're getting 61
years worth of stuff in like what 10
minutes yeah yeah it's a lot but
uh what led you to these realizations
a combination of
this is what i chose to be born to do
and this is what i've chosen to pay
attention to
you know i mean
there's
our original
you know plan
that we came into this life to
accomplish
um
it is always up for editing right like
we we we have sovereignty we can change
it at any time
you know you can you can walk down the
path or you can take a left or right or
whatever you want you know you can
remember how to fly and not even deal
with a path
right
so i i've chosen
to pay attention
right and one of the reasons i did that
is because to not pay attention was
painful agreed
yeah
[Music]
do other people know that
there is uh
something to pay attention to
i think you you know the answer that
question well is what's the answer
everybody does everybody knows that
everybody knows that on some level to
pay attention whether it be just a
little bit or a lot and then we make the
left or right decisions on whether to
pay attention or not right for some some
people like i said it's not
they become our habits is what
um enlightenment is not for every soul
in every lifetime
it's not every every soul's mission in
every lifetime to become enlightened
to manifest enlightenment because
frankly
everybody's already enlightened we come
from the light
we are the light
right
we've come into
this creation to experience
you know something else that we create
we're creating we're creating this we're
creating you know we've created all this
there's an aspect
i like to say that there's like there's
like four main kind of people right
there's the folks the souls that help
the universe create this
create what the universe okay all right
the folks that help the universe be
created yeah they help the the source of
the one create
the the realms of density that sounds
like an exciting job
doesn't it that's what they thought
a universe once once they once they
created it
that's what we all are that's what we
all do we all have that capacity we
create universes
right
so most of us do it on on the small
scale we do it in our heads yeah you
know but it's the same same thing a lot
of people you know you you build a house
you know you fill it with all your stuff
and you go to your job and i mean that's
your little universe
right
everybody's got one
whether it's a a bedroll or a a mansion
right
but what i'm talking about is
in the beginning there was
you know this group of people group of
souls that that
decided to create this what's the
beginning
it's an illusion okay okay i'm just for
the sake of the conversation i'm i'm
saying okay so there are these folks a
group of souls a group of souls who are
these they were they are us they're they
are we it's we it's all it's conscious
where everybody's everybody everybody is
everybody because remember there's just
one
we're all one
right so different aspects of divinity
decided to create
something right and they created this
and they created that and they created
the other thing and then one day they
created
the day
right they created
the universe they created the realms of
density the the you know those planes i
mentioned before right
and they kept creating creating creating
in the and what was really cool in this
game and the playground of
of all of all that is
was
that they could the more they created
the more fun they were having and the
what what do kids love to do during
recess
pretend
right so they they
went into their
playground and they everybody's i'll
i'll be this and you'd be that and we'll
pretend that we're this and that and
then and the best part about pretending
is when you totally thoroughly forget
everything else
except the game
right
so
they got
you know deep into their
thing into their creation
and then
some of them got stuck in there and
forgot completely
who they really are and where they
really came from right so
um
but once this thing was created there
were other aspects of divinity that that
realized that hey
there's this really cool place to go
let's go in there and see what it's all
about so they came in here and they you
know those are mostly the tourists
you know that they're just here because
it's fun
it was already they didn't create it but
they
came to visit
and they you know got caught up inside
and
you know
believing and believing and believing in
it right and then
there's uh
there's these other folks that got
invited
to come in to this construct
and
remind those around them
of who they really are and where they
really came from and
you know
to help
you know anybody that really wants to
not actually be in here anymore to like
leave
that's kind of what i feel like my role
is i figured
you could you could tell who those folks
are because
uh
they're usually the ones that are in
service
right they're
spiritual service trying to make the
world a better place and trying to help
people and it's it's your natural
proclivity is to try to that's most the
people that are watching this that's
your audience you know people that are
that are that want to do some good you
know they'd rather do good than do
anything else
right how can i help
right
then there's this this other group of
people and everybody knows this group of
people at least one of them right in
your lifetime
and their
mission
is to
explore
the darkness
right explore the boundaries
of the creation
right and those folks
they are fulfilling the prime directive
of
the source of the one
which is to experience the illusion of
being separate from itself
as much as possible for as you know to
go as far and deep into the darkness as
you possibly can
right
and
we all know those folks we you know we
try to help them like wake up no come
back no you know but that's their thing
that's what they're there for because on
some level
the universe the source of the universe
knows that we cannot be harmed and we
can do no harm
because this is an illusion
you know if you're invested in
in the physicality of things that just
just doesn't stand with you you know
it's no i'm going to save you you know
when
the universe knows
they have an agreement you know and in
native american
spirituality they under they there are
certain roles
you know there's a hayoka right and the
sacred clowns and the contrary what are
those
they're
the contrary you know they're the sacred
clown
um
they're uh
what would you you know i guess you
would call them medicine people that
that uh provide a service
[Music]
of reminding
you know it's a it's
kind of the the shaman yeah okay is to
be the mirror
you know if everybody's going right they
go left
you know if you go to if you go to a
sundance right
like everybody is wearing
uh
red
and white
and they're wearing black and green
everybody's going clockwise they go
counterclockwise you know everybody
everybody gets pierced in the front they
get pierced in the back
you know what i mean it's a it's a
recognized it's recognized like
non-conformist right and also healing
right so
example okay so i'm at this this
sundance at big mountain
20 years ago
and and there is a there is a
um a hayoka who has
um
he's been
you can tell
when when a man takes what whenever
hayoka takes off his shirt man a woman
right and they that they a sundancer
you can just see the piercings
layers and layers of piercings right
front and back
all right
and so everybody
at the sundance there's all this
um
attention to detail like if somebody
were to drop
an eagle feather they would stop the
whole ceremony
you know so there's like this intense
respect
because it's you know it's a four-day
prayer
for not for oneself but for
the world for humanity for your your
community it's for somebody else that
you're doing the dance right
and
and so you know from from sunrise to
sunset people are you know piercing and
they're they're attached to the arbor
and they're dancing and everything like
that
so this hayoka
you know goes out into the
into the sacred space
and he's got a can of soda
and he's got an electric
fan and he's just like ah man you know
just
being profane
right but at the same time he's doing
that he's checking
on the dancers
you know
he's he's
entering
um the notion of of light
of being lighter
of lightening up
of humor the sacred clown yeah yeah okay
you know yeah
so
that's the
that
percentage of people their their job is
to go
into the darkness
what about the other ones
what are the what are the rest is it
just lightning the majority of people
like i said are tourists are tourists
they're we're just here to play we're
here to immerse ourselves
in this construct
as thoroughly as we possibly can the
illusion of the surprise of being
separate from the one yeah the source of
the one separate from the one yeah so
majority people are tourists in that
experience and some are in the deep
malevolence
well i wouldn't say the deep sorry the
darkness the deep darkness yeah they're
exploring everybody's exploring the
darkness because all this is just it's
beyond the realm what i would call what
i what i tend to call the ultimate
reality which is beyond the realms of
density where we all come from you know
in the realms
about that how do we know about this
infinite consciousness place
how do we know about it yeah
by paying attention how do we how do we
pay attention to understand that we came
from there it's a walking meditation bro
right
okay it's a choice
pay attention you know when you go into
the wilderness
and
drop into stillness
whether you're just you know sitting in
your car
or you're literally in the desert or
out in the jungle or the
forest or i'm sitting on top of that
mountain over there
right
when you drop into
that
you open up a place
for communion to take place for a divine
community you you say i'm ready yeah
let's have a look
you have my undivided attention yeah
yeah
what's up
yeah right
so imagine if you go into that space
without wanting anything without needing
anything but
choosing
communion
right
so in 1993-94 i went into the desert
about 100 miles east of here
drove out there with a my volkswagen bus
i had a
bag of rice and a roll of canvas
and just intending to have you know
paint my brains out and have a
conversation with the universe
right
and within three to five days i started
to have
this experience of euphoria
and this euphoria
lasted ended up lasting for like three
months
24 hours a day
and no no drugs just paint and
no the the first two weeks no drugs at
all
then on new year's
eve
um i was given a head of acid
psychedelics yeah
and i
you know i tripped and i i couldn't wait
for it to be over so i could get back to
being high right and then the next life
on flight on
what i was experiencing the art the
painting your brains out on being
unbeaten
i would just i would just walk out into
the desert because this world is enough
this world is just beautiful enough to
be in ecstasy all the time well
there's that but it wasn't just this
world i mean i i would walk out into
the desert and i would just
you know stand there and and all this
information would start to come
just this like profusion of just
yumminess a feeling of of grace and
blessing blessedness and
um
that which can't not be named right
and
next thing i know i realize that i've
been standing there for like 20 minutes
a half an hour so you know just like
totally gorging myself on this feast of
the feeling and all the information and
everything and you know i love
information i love
knowledge i love uh consciousness right
and i was i was in communion
with the source of the one yeah right
and so it feels like that going really
deep into meditation or deep into
psychedelics
that that's what it feels like a deep
communion with the one that's exactly
what it feels like in many ways but so
so that is one of the ways for
for people
that are trying to to help others
communist is to get that tapping into
the interconnectedness of the one right
right and that though the self is the
illusion that the there is no
the the oneness is everything yeah
um i want to make i want to finish
something and make sure that something
really is some question more questions
okay yeah so
then the next day
um i had some friends that that came
into the desert and they they wanted me
to smoke this pot and i was like i'm
good but the universe said no
smoke the pot i was like really i just
want to be you know no no go ahead so i
smoked the pot and i went out into the
desert and i once again i couldn't wait
for it to be over so i could get back to
being high and i asked the universe it's
like why did you have me do this yeah
and the answer was so that i would know
that the similarities and differences
from what from the natural high that i
was experiencing
to these you know these substances
that most people use either you know
acid and i think about using uh
drugs in a very similar way to to know
the real difference in the feelings of
being high on life versus high on the
drug right well it's very it's really
simple
that
these
substances
they
they can only do for you what you can do
for yourself
like they literally only stimulate
what's already inside of you
to secrete the the problem is that they
they modify that secretion
right so like like acid and and
mushrooms and all that kind of stuff
they all stimulate this crystal palace
series of glands secrete their natural
you know you know serotonin melatonin
endorphins all this kind of stuff right
but because you have you've taken those
drugs
you they like like ecstasy i never i've
never done ecstasy but
but i'm i'm told that it it it
stimulates the
pineal gland
to to release all of the serotonin and
all the melatonin within it all at once
okay and that's why people that after
the after they've done it that a lot of
people don't you know for a couple of
days after they don't drink because
serotonin melatonin is what stimulates
the dreaming right
um so your your body is physically
compelled to respond to these chemicals
that you put in whereas you can do the
same thing
with with just your awareness you can
just by choosing
to be
in communion
right you can also do the same thing
that bliss that ecstasy
you can also do it through through the
breath through the breath yeah right
yeah so what what you had questions yeah
there's some yeah you got some questions
and it's an infinite it's an infinite
amount of questions
even even picking the next question is
hard um
um do you
um
do you feel as though
the trajectory of civilization is
a-okay no matter no matter what um do
you feel like we need to be focused on
something specific geopolitically to get
to the oneness so that we don't cause
significant errors in existential
threats or anything
to let more children birth and
experience this etc you mean do we need
to get rid of trump
is that what you're asking
maybe do we need to get rid of like
nuclear weapons do we need wouldn't that
be great
let's do that
can we agree
let's do that let's hope everyone boom
we're on our way
i think so
we're still here
even after the cold war we're still here
yeah yeah when i was born 57 man my
father was in the air force right i was
born in an air force base
and
there's you know
defcon 2 or whatever
we're on you know they were on
global alert yeah
yeah until what the 90s
so my whole life from 1957 until 1991
when the wall fell
we were under threat of like blowing
ourselves to smithereens
and for the past up until
this year
the past two years since trump came in
there was no question about the fact
that that was you know that was taken
care of you know we were going to not
blow ourselves up
now we've got
somebody in the office that thinks that
it's okay
to like why don't we use those things
we bought all these beautiful weapons
why don't we use them you know that's
crazy
but
i see that the
you know this soul
like any other soul
has a mission
right
and
there isn't
infinite love loves infinitely every
soul
in existence
right even hitler
you know these these these souls take on
these roles for a reason
and they're catalysts he's certainly
been a catalyst
and he's inspired what is he inspired he
inspired
the the one if he hadn't been elected it
wouldn't have been a women's march the
day after he got elect he got in that
stepped into office right
if he hadn't been elected those hundred
you know there are 100 women 100 some
odd women have are now in congress
because of what
of him being elected and
which is not even half
of congress
but we're moving in that direction
i want to return conversation to
what
is going on
in the higher
realms planes of existence what these
intent driven journeys are to the
to this earth orbiting the star
and then
we remember
some some don't but some remember and
then
we go back to
renegotiate where we go
next
to the next rock orbiting a star not
necessarily we go outside of a physical
universe maybe to a different style of
universe to a different well the first
thing that happens is you leave the
physical dimension obviously right
but you don't have to
die in order to do that you can do that
in your sleep you can do that through
meditation you can do it through astral
projection you know lucid
[Music]
with full acidity leaving your body
basically
here in the physical
you're
you know grounded in the physical body
grounded in the physical plane
um you can communicate when you're out
of your body at night or through
meditation or whatever you can
communicate with
those are that are in
uh
places that are either more dense than
this
or
less than less what is more dense and
less dense than this
than the physical plane yeah there there
are places that that people
that souls create for themselves when
they feel that they have
um are as yet undeserving
of
um
returning to the one
that they they may they may feel like
they've done something or
uh
that that would make them
unworthy of
returning to infinite love
right and so
they create these places to try to
punish themselves
right
and those places are
just more dense that's one
scenario about places that are denser
than here
um
you know there's obviously not as much
light
they are more dense the difference the
way to determine you know all the
different planes and everything it's all
us kind of just drawing lines to
infinite consciousness is all one thing
right
it the the determining factor is density
you know how dense is it
right obviously the physical plane is
more dense than the etheric and astral
and causal planes
right what are those
it like i said it all has to do with
with their places that are
planes of existence that are that are
less dense than the physical plane yeah
but what is the theory of
gastrointestinal
like i said though
you know like
that's what it is
there are certain places if you have a
um a guitar string you know we have a
string that's that's
strung taut
there are certain places where you if
you strum
it's not going to sound very good
right and there are certain places
where if you strum it's going to sound
pretty good
right you can hold it down and then
there's certain places
along there that are going to sound
perfect
right and there are certain places that
aren't going to sound like
anything you want to listen to
all right
so
each one of these planes is like that
they there's a coherence
that a sphere let's say
or zone
where things make sense to consciousness
you know to the consciousness that
you're
that you're
tuned into
all right
so you can you can look into
um
because there's an aspect of you on each
one of these coherent
places
in the realms of density
you have direct access to those places
if you so choose
when as and if it's not going to impinge
on you accomplishing what it is you came
here to do
look at that look man just trying to
understand i know
it's a lot it's a lot it's it's it's
exciting to
to aim to remember so
how about how about um
oh one more thing yeah
so
you know the the astral plane is where
most people go when they die let's say
right
um
and
most people when they think about you
know
disembodied spirits and interacting with
the other realms and all that kind of
stuff they're usually just dealing with
the the etheric and astral planes
right
so
to the astral plane to those folks on
the astral plane
the causal plane is that has the same
relationship
you know it's to them it's it's it's
just as
you know out there and it's hard to
uh or challenging to
commune with you know it's it's that
much of a
of a kind of a um
a step
like in music you know
the next
chord
that makes sense
are you with me well so remember the
guitar analogy with
where you can strum a guitar
for at a note that vibrates really well
so you kind of want to live your life
like that right but also
i don't know yet i guess okay
there's a piano over there right
so
um if you you hit all
middle c
right let's say middle c is a physical
plane
right there's a scale
based on on middle c
that you know in the middle of the of
the piano key there's 88 keys
and in the middle of it there's a c
scale right
so
there's
c scale below that
and it sounds deeper
right
and there's c scale above that that
sounds higher so you're going octaves up
right
all right thanks for giving me that word
i was like i knew this is
missing there right so it's a so this
this is a one octave the
etheric is at another octave the
is at another round we raise our octaves
raise them how do we how do we go up how
do we bring our consciousness up is that
the meditation and the one feelings of
oneness and
remember
it's important to remember one this is
just an analogy
two
there's an aspect of you
on every one of those
octaves
already there all
at the same time
right so maybe when i get some of the
darker feelings that's the more denser
octave and when you get the lighter
feelings that's uh
right
and and so then what do you do with that
so you can only
you can only access that
if it's your
part of your mission to do that and if
doing so is not going to impinge on what
it is you came here to do
that you're in this octave to do
but if you if you have the
if you feel like you need to
you know communicate with these higher
octaves
have at it you know at any time it's
your your call whether or not they can
they'll communicate that aspect will
communicate back with you is determined
whether or not it's gonna
mess you up in what you're really
trying to do came here to do
to the physical plan
what did you come to the physical plane
to do this
and what is this
what are we doing right this minute
just
aiming to have a conversation about
awakening and oneness
so
just the further dissemination of
awakening and oneness
inspiration towards that i feel similar
right yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i came to are we inevitably going
towards unity or
is it inevitable that we get to that
to an awakened state for more of the you
realize that it's already there is
just
oneness
right
yes
and the rest is illusion
it may be tasty illusion
but it's still illusion
doesn't it doesn't it at times feel like
the
ignorance is a parasite
i guess so bro if you say so
um
to you yeah i guess i'm not gonna if
that's how you feel that's cool
um
ignorance
uh is a
it serves a purpose yeah you were
talking about that earlier yeah yeah
that there are there are there is there
are experiences being had here
um that are only possible if you are
believing that this is all there is all
there is yeah yeah yeah
and that there's a purpose to though to
that those
that those experiences being had at this
time yeah
so so every so everything inherently has
one more thing yeah and and even if you
don't think that
the universe uses everything
right
the universe to the universe everything
is fertilizer
everything fertilizes everything else
nothing is wasted right
so whether you're aware of it or not the
universe is going to use whatever you're
doing
and whatever
is happening to
its greater purposes
straight up to its greater purposes like
like if i died right here right now
you know and nobody touched my body you
know the universe would make my body
disappear into the ground eventually
yeah you know
microbes would be happy yeah
all that kind of stuff and i would be
fertilizing this spot yeah you know
so
what do you think's the most beautiful
thing in the world
the world
that's usually my answer too
you know the whole thing man it's all
freaking isn't it friggin amazing yeah
yeah i mean just just like look at that
right there see that airplane yeah it's
an incredible feat you know you know
what you might like this phrase
look at that i call it look i call i
call it see a bird make a plane thrown
away like a coffee cup
so literally a hundred years ago it was
like oh my gosh look we can do that yeah
and then we went through a several
decade process of making airplanes and
now they're almost 200 000 commercial
flights happen a day and you get off the
commercial flight you throw the idea
away like a coffee cup yeah really
really and people people get in those
things
and then they pull down the window
i'm like are you kidding me
you're flying across america you're not
gonna like look out the window
i didn't like
150 years ago people were like
you know gotta have a covered wagon try
to get our horse and people walked
across america just to get to california
man
six months yeah
crazy happy here good man
what is time
that's a great question
um
you know what what comes to mind is
there's this thing is that that time is
a function of gravity
it's a you know
it's just something i've i've heard and
i'm like really
i'm it's something i'm
like mental bubble gum you know what i
mean just
chew that up a little bit
um it's all relative man
whatever time is is definitely relative
because
you know
there's an eternity in every moment
and there's an infinite number of
eternities in every moment
you know depending on your perspective
or it could be
just us waiting
standing in line behind somebody else
waiting for something else to happen
you know
or you know we're having an epiphany
if all of you is happening in all of the
different
octaves all at once are you not also
happening all at once in all of your
ages
right now exactly all time is
simultaneous
yeah the non-linearity of time well see
there's that once again it brings us
back to
you
know the source of
of infinite consciousness right it knows
all there is to know it is everything
there is to
that there is
right
and so at the moment of the of the
creation
the first moment of the creation it knew
the whole every scintilla of the
creation
and so in that model it to me it's like
the source of infinite consciousness
loves
to be surprised
being surprised is like
it's like dessert yeah you know what i
mean surprise me
because i know everything
but try to surprise me it surprised me
anyway
and i think that's one of the reasons
why humanity you know because we
surprise ourselves every friggin day
you know i mean i i'm
surprised myself right now
may not look like it
but i'm you know i'm i'm i'm constantly
amazed
by
you know like where i find myself what
i'm
what i
find myself being doing so forth you
know and i
i think
what if i'm capable of it most people
are as well
you know
so
hmm
look at that how do you feel
how do you feel about exponential
technology exponential exponential
technology what are we talking about
just that
we now have
these incredible computers and phones
that are
super incredible
better than what was used to get to the
moon helicopters
yeah you can hear it
um
biotechnology neurotechnology just
mapping things out really well in the
brain and in the body the genome
sequencing etc is all just dropping in
price and increasing in speed etc
it's wonderful isn't it
it's freaking amazing do you think there
are any negative aspects to exponential
technology right so positive and
negative are on a spectrum okay
of
being in existence
right okay so it's only value it's all
love even the negative is love
ultimately it has to be right because
all there is is infinite consciousness
and infant consciousness is infinite
love
right
but
to get a little more specific there is
[Music]
um
you know i'm an astrologer and a student
of history right i look at the big
picture i spent a lot of time
big history i love big history
you know like like
the history of the universe exactly the
history of
existence of civilization and the 100
billion people lived and died to build
this world yeah right right and so
so it's obvious that there is
um
in 1903
the the wright brothers
flew
in kitty hawk
and
uh 66 years later
we were walking on the moon
that's pretty great 66 years that's
pretty good before before that it's
actually incredible yeah yeah that's
probably the biggest human
accomplishment ever right
and the fastest time period ever so the
computing power in this
in my hand right now is more
than what landed us on the moon yeah
which was
60 almost 66 years ago
right yeah exactly
exactly
isn't it credible yeah
it's just so it's obvious
okay okay all right so
um
i got you all excited yeah yeah
population
yes
um up until
1900 around 1900 the human population
was under a billion souls incarnate at
once
yeah it was around that time yeah right
then we had 6 billion in the last 100
years yeah so yeah
right now we're approaching
seven we're approaching seven point
eight billion sold so yeah okay
that's how many souls are so there's a
soul in every person right but there
aren't like there's not fractaling of
souls like there's not one soul being
shared across of course there is all
there is remember what part of
all is one always will not forget yeah
yeah
so then your soul bathes in mine mind
bids and yours and whatnot the
interconnectedness of things yeah
ultimately we all come from the world
but there are 7.7 plus billion right now
souls and we're approaching 7.8 which
isn't a harmonic with the base frequency
of the earth the human resonance
right for the person the base frequency
of the earth
is 7.8 hertz
right
is that the frequency of the crust or
where
it's a frequency of uh the planet
overall based on
on um the three to four thousand
lightning strikes that happen every day
caused the
frequency of the earth to you know
vibrate at that frequency 7.8
interesting cycles per second right
which is in a harmonic with
the ambient
vibration of the universe
the the wavelength of the ambient
vibration of the universe is is 7.3
sine cosine
centimeters
right
so it's like
we're in this for the first time
in
recorded history
uh the number of incarnate souls is
coming into a harmonic with the base
frequency of the earth and the ambient
vibration of the universe
in our lifetime sometime within the next
year
so but what why why so but
because i'm trying to understand this so
i'm trying to paraphrase it because
otherwise i don't think i understand
so
7.8 billion sold 7.8 hertz frequency of
the planet
and that is synchronous check it out
since the last world destruction around
12 000 years ago
to 1900 less than a billion souls at the
same time on the planet
right world destruction
world destruction 12 000 years ago yeah
what was the world destruction okay
so according to the hopi oral tradition
there have been three previous world
destructions in the past hundred
thousand years the first time destroyed
one the first time by fire the second
time by ice and the third time by flood
right okay the most recent one
was what was it hokey
hopi what's hopi the hopi are the
native american
that that live
um
in northeastern arizona okay okay three
previous yeah their oral tradition goes
back through three previous world
destruction okay and
the most recent one damn they've logged
that's good that's good lineage yeah
yeah but they've had the information now
yeah look they've had the oral the oral
tradition okay
now it's only been within the past
you might want to know this yeah
in while i was having that spiritual
acceleration back in the winter of
1993-94
i discovered an archaeological site in
big sur
that i feel may be connected to the hopi
story of the survivors of glassware
purification by flood and their place of
emergence into the fourth world
and i i made a movie about it
and you know
released it in
2010. is that on your website yeah it's
on youtube and you can watch it for free
it's a 90-minute website again is the
david alexander english dot com david
alexander english dot com or da english
dot com d a english dot com yeah that's
what i was thinking right then the links
in the bio and you have your books there
yeah and you have your music music there
and your painting movie and paintings
i discovered the site
the first site and then over the next
20 years i discovered two more sites
within five miles of the of that first
site
they're all
um have something to do with celestial
observation
except social observatories
and
um it turns out that
they are in the national forest and the
forest service didn't know anything
about it until i showed them the
photographs
of the sites that i took in 2004
and
so i made a movie about this whole the
whole thing for for 10 years the first
10 years afterwards
i i after the first initial discovery i
thought
that
it was common knowledge i thought that
the forest service knew about it and
other people knew about it and i tried
to find out what they knew and then i it
wasn't until 10 years later i was
actually able to talk to the zone
archaeologists and discover that they
had no idea that the site
were there
and so
i made the movie in 20 2010
and then i made it free i put it on
youtube in in 2012 and published a book
version of it it's a straight transcript
excuse me
around that same time
you know i was working on the sequel to
that
movie in the book
and
all this information started to come out
um the scientific information
that
uh
i i've been trying to understand what
about
um these
previous when did these previous world
destructions take place yes in terms of
just history and science yes right
and it turns out that
around 2012
we discovered
when
the
middle destruction took place one
um
about 41 000 years ago and that was by
fire no the first was by fire second by
ice in the third by flood that was the
ice destruction right and
um there were two different scientific
studies one was looking at the gene
the greenland ice cores and one was
looking at
the north sea lava flows and they both
determined that there had been a polar
shift
of magnetic pole shift that happened 41
000 years ago
and
[Music]
the oral tradition of the hopi say that
when the nephew of the great spirit was
was ready to purify the world for the
second time
he told those to remember that to keep
the tops of their heads open to the rest
of the universe to go into the earth and
join the ant people for the second time
and once they were safely inside he told
the twins who were stationed at the
poles to leave their station immediately
the earth rolled over twice
fell off its axis rolled over twice the
oceans flopped over the land the
mountains fell into the sea
and as everything froze
[Music]
and
the the earth wandered through space for
years
before
um you know starting up its rotation
again
okay
so
that's crazy that's crazy it sounds
crazy and what's amazing about that that
oral tradition is that is an eyewitness
account
of
witnessing a magnetic pole shift and
then what did how did they retain that
through generation
brother if there was an ice age though
that killed everyone
the ice age didn't kill everyone
obviously
and
um
according to the hopi the
the the second world i mean excuse me
the third world began again after the
you know the earth started to rotate
again right
and it was a very technological age
so much so that that there were actually
um
what they called shields that flew
between cities
[Music]
that's how technological that age was
and that age was ended by a flood
okay
so
around the same time around 20 between
2012 and two years ago
this other information scientific
information came up where
they've discovered
what that there was a flood and when
that flood took place that that flood
took place between
12 000 900 years ago and 11 600 years
ago and then what was the significance
of having just one billion souls and now
up to okay so after that after the world
was destroyed the third time
by flood
you know it wiped out most the majority
of the population of the world
so
right now there are more souls incarnate
than there have been in the past since
the last world destruction
right in the past 10 000 or 12 thousand
years
right so
how we got into this part of this
conversation was you were asking me
about
you know my take on
the exponential growth of technology
okay
so we are at
um a place
that it's obvious that
you know
just in in that there's a
an exponential growth in population
is an exponential growth in
in technology and
that all of this is being driven from
the other side of the veil
okay what does that mean the veil is the
the membrane separating the physical
universe from the rest of creation
and how is the population growth and
technology growth coming from the what
the non-physical side of the veil right
and it's really simple
um
that's where we come from
nobody is here by mistake nobody just
kind of stumbled into being born
right
every soul that comes into this life
is arrives here
through
agreement
with their higher so their higher self
and the super conscious beings that are
are
um
uh keeping track of the whole soul group
and
and um
you know you construct a a lifetime
as a as a healing or as a gift to the
collective consciousness right
um so nobody gets here by mistake
everybody gets here by agreement and by
choice right
and the only way like what you said
earlier
how many souls did it how many lifetimes
did it take
to build up the infrastructure the
physical infrastructures to support 7.8
billion souls being incarnate at the
same time
10 000 years 10 000 years and all and
all these
you know all the our ancestors yeah
right yeah what they did created helped
to create civilization
create enough
of a of a physical infrastructure that
could support seven point eight seven
point eight eight being sold and and
where did all those souls come from they
came from the other side of the bill how
do how does somebody get
technology
you get it from paying attention to the
universe you get it
right from from ideas and from the
metaphysical realm and then you can
tweak the science because you are you
understand the rules the laws of the
nations it's all coming from infinite
consciousness
right being in communion with infinite
consciousness you get an idea yeah yeah
yeah right yeah that's through your
dreams your visions your thoughts yeah
that's awesome
right
so what i'm saying is that all of this
is coming from the uh you know this
there's an agenda
that's manifesting
is it our agenda yeah so
they are we it's not there's just us out
here it's our agenda from the
higher yes all of us and the whole
we brought we bring our intent here
right
we're doing this do you do a quick quick
uh quick this one we gotta we gotta wrap
it up rob so
this universe is designed with
math and science and love and
consciousness and it's designed with
rocks orbiting stars in space
what other kinds of universes have you
imagined
have i imagine yeah
it's boundless bro it's whatever you
want to what about you though
specifically what other kind of
universes exist out there that may not
have green grass green trees blue oceans
but rather completely different dr seuss
why do ask
because i want i love universe design
and i bet your mind has wandered into
some of that
you know like i said it's boundless
you know i i do that's what i do all day
long you know is make stuff up i'm a
professional make stuff upper you know
professional dreamer yeah you know
that's what i do so
you know how many hours in the day you
you don't have enough tape
[Music]
yeah the bat it's the batteries it's the
batteries
man well yeah because i spent the first
half at another interview today yeah
yeah and i still want to kept some
b-roll um okay we'll have to do another
episode
i'm based in san francisco so come when
you come and visit let us know all right
and you can join us in the studio up
there i'll let you know when we come
back to la
david alexander english what a
pleasure my brother
not just a pleasure
my man
everyone da english check out the links
in the bio also go and spur these
conversations with other epic people
around you let's get these conversations
rolling
also go and build the future everyone go
manifest your destiny into the world we
love you so much as if you could do
something else as if you could do
something else that's right that's right
we love you so much
and we'll see you soon
also support awesome artists yes
like david english like alan stock and
what we're doing here with simulation
all those links are below support
artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in that you want to make a
better impact on the world that's it
baby that's it much love we love you so
much peace
thank you thank you very much